les chéris car antoine on va faire jouer
les chroniqueurs je veux donner des
informations sur wes qu'elle sombre
escaut sont fausses à clara morgane a
fait sa première télé dans apostrophe
vrai nom est bien vrai non c'est pas
vrai à voir le prof tech bernard pis
vous ne vous rappelle votre tv ou par
ckoi spécialement mardi avec le
christophe dechavanne alors merde j'ai
tiré ardisson d'ici dit oui d'accord oui
mais enfin c'est passionnant même temps
nous livrons très bien dans l'aisne
semaines on atteint première interview
télé c'était chez thierry ardisson fois
que chez christophe dechavanne ses trios
quand même regarde comme un souvenir
la première fois à tout de suite barry
rentrée premier mensonge il n'a pas duré
longtemps
c'est une tromperie les tromper blague
oui non mais ça durait deux jours que je
lis j
[Applaudissements]
la passion je vais te bats ya très
longtemps mais je te jure c'était en
2001 sans 2001 et ouest et à 16 ans
j'avais 19 ans avait 19 ans donc que
maintenant tu en as beau aussi merci
gériatre antoine de caunes a fait sa
première telle à l'âge de deux ans oui
oui oui
ouais c'est vrai c'est vrai c'était en
compagnie de votre mère jacqueline
joubert sur moi geof sont je sais pas je
m'en souviens pas où j'avais deux ans
regarde tu avais deux tons peux pas t'en
souvenir
tu as fait et tu as fait ta première
télé avant michel drucker terre des sols
des avocats n'étaient pas encore nés oui
c'est énorme je regarde aileurs parce
que maintenant j'ai rendez vous avec un
jeune homme
vous avez quand même avec antoine et
bien antoine jacqueline bond comme la
mairie
je ne sais pas je ne savais pas c'est
qu'ils avaient tiré en descendant la
voiture la première fois qui m'a fait ma
première fois et à la même tête mais
christine arron c'est surtout le double
oui c'est tout de même de vous partez
directement sur le grand cabaret de
couteau je suis plus un camp toi malgré
tout mais j'étais très ami avec son père
adorait son père voilà vos amis là je
disais ça vous a mis deux coups dans la
gueule juste amis oui juste amis juste à
me mettrai à me maudire les amis c'est
quoi bon maintenant delorme est vraiment
le pauvre rien de sexuel mais on était
très amis et c'était justement pour ça
qu on était très amis d'accord traite et
13h06 d'antoine on sert actuellement une
petite angoisse alors ça ne l'inquiète
pas on a également récupéré les images
de ta première émission sera pas
s'appeler comment ta première mission
chorus ouais c'est ça c'est diffusé sur
france 2 en étant 19h10 je me souviens
bien quelques minutes pour vous
présenter quelques disques antoine
d'abord le nouveau mad man neuvième
album de magma un des groupes les plus
extraordinaires qu'ils soient et un
tournant important dans la musique de
christian vander donc aux russes le 15
octobre
ensuite le deuxième disque de wayne
county un musicien qui se prend parfois
pour ramsès ii ou pour dracula et qui en
tous les cas connaît très bien le rock
pour toi tu t'éclates avec la nouvelle
émission par là avec l'angola et one way
d'éclat m'amuse comme un fou je vais te
dire un truc
mine de rien on va pas se mentir c'est
ce qu'on disait avant l'émission tu
cartonné à 19 heures sur canal avec plus
d'un million nous les joues sa manche un
énorme serpent qui sert le manque en
fait de faire de la télévision de
plateau comme ça non nordea nettement
non tu t'égares plus à faire tes trucs
oui enfin moi j'adore j'ai commencé par
ça j'ai commencé par faire venir des
groupes ensuite dans les enfants du rock
j'allais faire des reportages et en fait
quand je me suis retrouvé sur des
plateaux de télé avec les contraintes à
des déchets avec la ligne 1 non non lui
et lui c'est sa nature il adore ça moi
j'aime bien sortir mais bien j'aime bien
les tournois extérieurs
je vais te dire un truc on donne ce
qu'on est dans le même groupe - ya plein
de gens qui me parlent et qui me disait
antoine c'est vrai que il y avait des
producteurs qui disait il faut lancer la
pub à telle heure antoine et échoue je
te jure à chaque fois le brasier
antoine c'est un artiste amanda il faut
le laisser faire faire ce qu'il veut
faire et c'est vrai que moi je sais les
taux devraient tu des lancers la pub à
44 ont été dans un truc tyson faisait
chier de c'est toutes ces contraintes la
quitteront chez posséder oui et c'est
amusant
ouais ça sa fille risque est un exercice
donc pas toi moi il ya les contraintes
moi je dirais contrainte c'est un
exercice te dit et on peut le dire
maintenant que tu as réussi avec brio
parce qu'il ya un million à 19 heures
sur canal voilà il faut qu'elles n'ont
pas ce qu'il fait marrant ça c'était de
passer 2 je sais pas moi
mais tu avais manuel valls après tu
avais bertrand taylor swift c'est ça
c'est ça que c'est ça qu'on l'aimé aussi
et bravo bravo parce que disait tout à
l'heure et oui clara morgane a déjà
pécho géraldine maillet oui ça reste tu
te rappelles alors oui à la radio
enghien pour le moment de radio
après ça j'ai arrêté rideau terminé
merci à regarder c'est à mes chronos
elles s'embrassent langoureusement alors
n'ont marqué que sept secondes ça fait
que ces deux secondes ça fait que ça
tourne il en reste encore treize jeux
les mêmes ondes radio ça m et ses
pinceaux kamal est bas
[Applaudissements]
il me l'a demandé nous n'avons pas
résisté
oui bah je demanderai plus rien au
regard du tissu quoi bah oui elles ont
l'air de kiffer pardon si ça bouge
arrivera un jour vous verrez il faisait
quoi ressemble à nos mamans pendant 20
jours
mais moi j'étais jeune je chronométrait
c'est vrai mais c'est un très bon moment
à la radio ça cartonnait
[Rires]
radiophoniquement s'est laissée après ça
qui nous ont arrêtés nouveau antoine de
caunes a formé un célèbre duo avec
monsieur d'ovale avec monsieur d'ovale
josé do vale bien sûr j'étais resté pote
encore avec choisi mais évidemment on
peut pas ne pas être pote avec josé
sicile ne pas être otage josé oui tu
veux donner son numéro là on a fait une
petite compil de vos meilleurs
personnages rendus le part ailleurs sur
canal + entre 87 et 95 que c'est une des
émissions les plus cultes de la
télévision à seysses et toujours les
missions qu'on prend en exemple ce qui
me fait rire c'est que dans les couloirs
de canal+ depuis des années on entends
tu vas être faudrait refaire comme doc
odt et garcia tuera comme ça c'est un
truc que vous entendez dans toutes les
chaînes depuis 15 ans
tout le monde veut refaire nulle part
ailleurs avec josé garcia antoine de
caunes et bien sûr philippe gildas
conforme à ce qui nous regarde souvent
regard des élèves face à chelsea
je disais donc que votre dernier ouvrage
mesdames et messieurs semestre m'a
séduite
là vous devez prouver la vie tchô les
trajets en europe
bref ni moubarak l'egypte c'est sûr
qu'on s'y quand tout seul ne risque pas
trop se prendre d'état dans sa gueule
c'est moins risqué
s'il essayait avec moi par exemple quoi
oui je ne crois pas les héros
s'appellent
m
antoine de caunes et cardiaques